we're gonna call these cheesie's also  known as cheap Easy's  [Music]  we're gonna see if it works I'm a little  skeptical what I personally wear these  at this moment in time yeah this is  gonna be a no from me right now so Shay  originally used no skid shoe pads for  the sole of the shoe so we could not  find those so we're gonna use some  sandpaper and some duct tape it's a  little janky we do realize thank you so  much what we're gonna work with what we  have  moving on to our second pair so we've  finished both pairs of heels we're gonna  return these to our friend Caroline and  see if she's an awesome I love your  sandpaper edition I actually like these  shoes after wearing them I mean I did  think they were kind of hideous at first  but they were comfortable and not too  bad I like these ones I like them a lot  the sand paper isn't slipping off  they're cut off sexy in a way Monica you  did a great job with these shoes for a  first-timer you nailed it  [Music]